the African union says it will proceed
with its troop withdrawal from Somalia
as scheduled last week Morad disu
requested a 90-day pause through the UN
Security Council on the pull out of
forces officials made the request after
an increase in attacks by armed groups
3,000 members of the African Union
transition in Somalia are scheduled to
leave by the end of September let's
speak to Malcolm web for more on this
who is in Nairobi and mcol can you
explain for us why the Somali government
asked for a 9 pause and what's going to
come
next it was about a year ago when the
Somali federal government uh launched
operations against the armed group
al-shabab with us trained Special Forces
erran trained soldiers uh also fighting
alongside uh Clan militias armed uh by
the federal government and those
operations seem to have had success or
at least relative success compared to
the previous 15 years of operations uh
by troops provided by other African
countries under the banner of an African
Union uh and United Nations authorized
uh Force now that Force depended on
support and funding from the US and the
European Union uh both of whom in recent
years appear to have had uh some fatigue
tired of this never ending game of cat
and mouse in which the forces they were
supporting held uh a green zone in the
capital Morad to the centers of of some
other cities but al-shabab uh controlled
the countryside and ran uh effectively a
nationwide Mafia collecting uh vast sums
of Revenue the Somali government
offensives had more success and so uh
the US has refocused its resources
towards training Somali Soldiers the
European Union uh says uh that it's
running out of budget to supp to support
the foreign uh forces anymore now the
Somali government says just in recent
weeks it's suffered some some setbacks
and that several towns his forces have
had to retreat from al-shabab has taken
them back and for that reason uh it's
asked for the African Union troops uh to
stay for 90 more days now there seems to
be uh some tension here but when we
speak of the African Union it's
important to bear in mind that this is
an organization without a lot of
political leverage itself and without
any significant budget the key players
in question are the troop contributing
countries that's Uganda Kenya Ethiopia
jibuti and Bundi now the African Union
has refused somalia's request to extend
these 3,000 troops for another 90 days
so from what we know now according to
what the African Union has said those
troops will withdraw uh at the end of
this month okay thanks so much that is
Malcolm whb for us in Nairobi